- as surprising an almost humiliating
extent some of the gravest problems we
face during a day can be traced back to
a brutally simple fact that we have not
had enough sleep the night before the
idea sounds profoundly offensive there
are surely greater issues from tiredness
we're likely to be up against genuine
hurdles the economic situation politics
of problems of work tensions in our
relationship the family these are true
difficulties but what we often fail to
appreciate is the extent to which our
ability to confront them with courage
and resilience is dependent on a range
of distinctly small or low factors what
our blood sugar level is like when we
last had a proper hug from someone how
much water we've drunk and how many
hours we've rested we tend to resist
such analyses of our troubles it can
feel like an insult to our rational
adult dignity to think that our sense of
gloom might in the end stem centrally
from exhaustion we'd sooner identify
ourselves as up against an existential
or socio-cultural crisis than see
ourselves as sleep-deprived yet we
should be careful of under but also of
over intellectualizing to be happy we
require large serious things money
freedom love but we need a lot of semi
insultingly little things - a good diet
hugs and rest anyone who has ever looked
after baby knows this well when life
becomes too much for them it's almost
always because they're tired thirsty or
hungry with this in mind it should be no
insult to insist that we never adopt a
truly tragic stance until we first
investigated whether we need to have
orange juice or lie down for a while
probably as a hangover from childhood
staying up late feels a little glamorous
and even exciting late at night is when
in theory the most fascinating things
out
but in a wiser culture than our own some
of the most revered people in the land
would on a regular basis be shown taking
to bed early there'd be competitions
highlighting sensible bedtimes we'd be
reminded of the pleasures of already
being in bed when the last of the
evening light still lingers in the sky
our problems would not thereby disappear
but our strength to confront them would
at points critically increase did you
know that the School of Life is actually
a place ten places in fact campuses all
over the world from Melbourne to London
Taipei to Istanbul with classes and
books and lots more please click on the
link below to explore more